[Music]
superhero movies have been the leading
genre in movie theaters for more than a
decade Marvel has been dominating the
market for many years but the high
number of films and Series has also had
a negative impact on the quality of the
Productions as for the dceu with the
suicide squad and Peacemaker they were
able to bring two hits to the screen in
2021 and 2022 respectively but which
movies are our favorite Heroes can we
look forward to in the next few years we
have browsed through the depths of the
web and summarized all the releases with
a brief description for you in this
video and of course there are again
quite a lot of promising movies for
everyone anyway enough of words and
let's get into the video
the year we'll begin with Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania the third solo film
from Scott Lang AKA Ant-Man will also
introduce the upcoming super villain
Kang to the big screen at last as the
trailer is already revealed to us Scott
Cassie hope Hank and Janet are pulled
into the quantum Realm by a device
developed by Scott's daughter there the
discovery Universe never seen before as
we could observe not only are there
little animals of all kinds but also
entire civilizations moreover Janet who
has spent years in the quantum realm
appears to keep a dark secret which she
has withheld from her family all this
time in order to escape from the
mysterious Dimension they seem to be
dependent on the help of a very special
person that of Kang the Lander seems to
know Scott or rather Ant-Man already or
at least that's how it looks from the
first footage we've seen in the film as
with the first two parts of Ant-Man
Peyton Reed will direct the sequel so we
can assume that the movie will not be
lacking in humor The Phase 5 film of the
MCU will be released on February 17th
the first DC Blockbuster we can expect
to see on the big screen in the new year
is Shazam Fury of the Gods in 2019 we
were able to see young Billy Batson for
the first time when he had the power of
the wizard Shazam passed on to him and
since then he has been living two
different lives as we know Shazam is
also part of the dceu and in the
recently released trailer we could find
all sorts of references to the other
superheroes from the franchise in his
second movie Shazam will have to deal
with the daughters of Atlas they don't
seem too thrilled about the fact that
kids have been given the power of the
Gods and thus want to reclaim these
Powers however a clash between Shazam
and Black Adam will not yet take place
in Shazam Fury of the Gods even though
the anti-hero who was embodied by Dwayne
The Rock Johnson was originally intended
to be shazam's great adversary following
the moderate success of Black Adam
though it remains to be seen how this
particular project will play out Shazam
Fury of the Gods will at least be
screened in cinemas from March 17th and
provided that it is as much of a mix of
humor and action as the first part it
will certainly be worth a trip to the
movies
it's James Gunn's big departure from the
MCU before he completely moves on to the
competing franchise the dceu and it is
arguably the most emotional farewell to
what is probably the most chaotic bunch
of superheroes the universe has ever
seen of course we're talking about the
Guardians of the Galaxy in their third
and final Standalone film Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. as we've already
pointed out in two videos we've made
about the movie it looks like it's going
to be a very touching one Gunn himself
has hinted in some interviews that not
all of the Guardians will make it out
alive and especially the story of Rocket
which we already got a glimpse of in the
first trailer should become very tragic
the Guardians will have to deal with two
powerful opponents in volume three one
is of course Adam Warlock and the other
is the high evolutionary who also
happens to be the creator of Rocket
whether things will continue with the
Guardians after this film is not yet
known Hollywood insiders however agree
that no one from the current cast will
be available for another Guardians of
the Galaxy movie that's why it's all the
more important for every fan to Rush the
movie theater starting May 5th 2023
because that's the day the movie
premieres
Spider-Man into the spider-verse was
probably the most successful superhero
movie made by Sony in 2018. Not only was
it very well received by critics and
fans it was also showered with countless
Awards including an Oscar for best
animated film while Miles Morales had to
Bid Farewell to his Spider-Man friends
at the end of the first part in this new
installment he is pulled into the
spider-verse and must come to the rescue
of his friends in various Dimensions at
the same time not every version of
Spider-Man looks to be a friend as we
saw in the latest trailer besides we
think every fan is dying to see what
will happen next with him and
spider-gwen as the two have already
gotten a little closer in the first part
the movie will be released on June 2nd
and is a must-see for anyone who has
watched more than enough of the MCU and
dceu
she is considered the Superman Paradox
in the MCU and is nevertheless more than
popular among fans yet we have only been
able to see her in two films however
that will change in 2023 the talk is of
course of Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel she returns to Cinemas in her
second Standalone film Captain Marvel 2
The Marvels well she won't be all alone
for she'll be assisted by Ms Marvel and
Monica Rambo Ms Marvel whose real name
is Kamala Khan made her first appearance
in the MCU with her series of the same
name in the summer of 2022 and as for
Monica we already know her from One
Division both of them got super powers
and in the post-credits scene of Ms
Marvel we could already see Carol as
well who exactly would be the bad guy in
the movie is not yet known but we think
it won't be too long before we get to
see the first images or even a trailer
for the movie it is scheduled for
release in the second half of the year
starting July 28th assuming nothing
changes before that
not only the MCU and dce are expanding
in the New Year the Sony Universe around
Venom is also getting a new anti-hero
this is Craven the hunter as the name
suggests Craven is a big game hunter who
loves to hunt down powerful and big
trophies thus over time it happens that
he also goes on the hunt for superheroes
his favorite trophy that he would like
to have would be Spider-Man Craven's
real name is Sergey cravenov and in the
comics he is the half-brother of the
chameleon also known as Dimitri
smardiakov Craven the hunter is played
by Aaron Taylor-Johnson he should
already be known to any Marvel fan as
one to maximoff's brother Quicksilver
whether we'll come to a clash with Venom
or morbius in the movie is not yet known
however signs that Sony is planning to
put a Sinister Six movie into production
sooner rather than later are becoming
stronger as a result of the film Craven
is the last super villain still missing
for the union of super villains also
involved will be Calypso and the
Foreigner thus there won't be a lack of
baddies the movie is expected to be
released in theaters on October 6 2022
and should there be any changes to of
the date you'll be sure to find it in
our weekly news
we do have to wait for a long time but
in about a year Jason Momoa will return
to his starring role as Aquaman the
first part was considered one of the
most successful DC EU movies ever and
therefore many fans are eagerly awaiting
the sequel the movie will see The Return
of Black Manta who did survive the last
fight with Aquaman orm better known as
Ocean Master will also be back to give
Arthur Curry a hard time also likely to
be back is Amber Heard there were many
questions surrounding her role in the
film after she got into trouble with her
ex-boyfriend Johnny Depp during a Civil
Trial as for the plot sadly not much is
really known yet but after such a long
shooting period we can only hope the
film can match the quality of the
previous one Aquaman in the lost kingdom
will be released on December 25th 2023
right on time for Christmas Day
the DC animated series Legion of
Superheroes will also get its own movie
in 2023 the movie is the sequel to the
series of the same name in it the future
superheroes trained to finally join the
legion one of them is Kara also known as
Supergirl following the destruction of
Krypton however she finds it difficult
to adjust to her new home planet of
Earth despite the fact that her cousin
Superman does everything in his power to
help her it's not until she arrives at
the superhero Academy and makes new
friends that things start to improve for
her yet her happiness is short-lived as
an organization called the dark circle
tries to destroy the academy the
animated film is expected to be released
on Blu-ray and digital on February 7th
2023
many were skeptical about how the new
Batman with Robert Pattinson in the lead
role will turn out but the Twilight star
has proven us wrong by showing that he
can do much more than being a mere
vampire the Batman was certainly one of
the darkest but also one of the best
superhero movies of 2022 which makes us
all the more excited for the second part
although it won't hit theaters until
2024 it is already one of the most
highly anticipated releases we also
already know who the bad guy is going to
be since we got to see him at the end of
the first film and who else could it be
but the Joker he is played by Barry
Keogan who most superhero fans among you
might have already seen in eternals in a
five-minute unpublished scene you were
already able to see the first
conversation between Batman and the
Joker and the performance of the super
villain is already enough to send
shivers down your spine whether Paul
Dano is the Riddler and Colin Farrell as
the penguin will find their way back
into the story is still unknown but the
latter will get his own series anyway
the movie is expected to be released in
2024 a more specific date has
unfortunately not been announced yet
a reboot has finally made it back into
the MCU although most of you may not
have known that it was based on a Marvel
movie we're talking about the Vampire
Hunter blade from the 1998 film of the
same name who was played by Wesley
Snipes at the time and goes out hunting
vampires at night however he himself is
a half vampire as his mother was bitten
by a vampire during her pregnancy since
he was born he is also known as
daywalker he has the same power as the
nocturnal creatures yet the sun doesn't
bother him and garlic and silver don't
seem to weaken him either in the new
part he'll be played by mahershala Ali
who was last seen in Swanson kit
Harrington is also likely to make his
second appearance in the MCU he was
introduced to the MCU in eternals and
will finally take on the role of the
Black Knight how the Vampire Hunter will
fit into the MCU remains to be seen as
his first movies were mainly dark and
gory which is nothing you would
recognize from past movies the
provisional release date so far is
September 6 2024 but a lot can still
change in the meantime
this was the first part of our superhero
preview of the next few years which
movie are you most looking forward to so
far let us know in the comments and if
you like this video feel free to leave a
thumbs up
[Music]